good evening uh all council members
members of this committee and others and
our officers who are with us thank you
for joining us for this meeting here
on the 19th of april 2022 of the
overview and scrutiny panel
i'd like to welcome joe as well
i know this lady's name because i know
there's a lady called joan who was going
to attempt to get here this evening
thank you for joining us we hope you'll
find that this
is an interesting meeting and it covers
the topic if not completely thoroughly
enough for you to be able to have some
of the information that you were looking
for members officers we do have a bit of
a technical glitch so this
meeting is not being live streamed i
understand it will be
i understand it will be recorded and be
available later but it is not being live
streamed for this evening
excuse me i'm sorry about the coffee
if the fire alarm is activated please
vacate excuse me
the office is down the main staircase
opposite the lifts in the foyer
assembled in hawley square
on the green and officers will assist us
and advise us when it's deemed
safe to return to the chamber
would everyone present please ensure
their mobile phones are either turned to
silent or in flight mode and they're not
used for any purposes really while this
meeting is in progress
does anyone intend to film the meeting
i don't think so so we can skip over the
comments about filming and maintaining
people's privacy
are there any members who wish to speak
under rule 20.1
thank you
councillor belly
the budget monitoring report
number nine which is now number five is
that right
number six
okay which is now number seven yeah okay
it's the coastal report
for those watching in black and white
the pink balls behind the red one um
yeah we've just um the supplementary
agenda item number nine has been bumped
up the agenda it's now the new number
five so everything else has been pushed
down one
but it's the coastal review council
daily yes thank you very much
um
any members of the public joan did you
want to have a word
while you're here
you're just going to listen all right
thank you very much i hope you didn't
mind me
inviting you
apologies for absence do we have any
apologies
i think we're all here
decorations of interest are there
decorate any decorations of interest
members may wish to make
and now we turn then to the minutes of
the previous meeting
can i have a proposal please and a
seconder to approve the minutes of the
overview and scrutiny panel meeting on
the 15th of march 2022
thank you very much
councillor fellows
and councilman
so you're not going to be on camera
cancel the bathroom but we get your best
side whichever way it is because you're
right in the middle there so i now call
upon uh councillor bob bayford who's
come to make a presentation to us he's
the cabinet
portfolio hold he's a member for
environmental services and special
projects he's coming to talk to us about
progress the council is making with its
climate emergency decoration
council between thank you very much
thanks chairman uh thank you members
officers um can i introduce dr hannah
scott for those of you that don't know
her she's the climate change officer and
she's put this presentation together so
if it's rotten it's her fault if it's
all right it's all my work
so
thank you very much
great to have this opportunity to come
along and talk about what we're doing at
the moment
after calling the climate emergency a
climate change officer group and the
cross party councillor working group was
established an initial climate change
action plan was written including both
low carbon and biodiversity aims
it cut across many departments of the
council including housing planning air
quality facilities the fleet open spaces
and the fanuc coastal project amongst
others
looking at housing and planning
in the original action plan the housing
department aimed to create new energy
efficient social housing with solar pv
and they've done this
with regards to planning the department
was tasked to write a local plan which
included sustainability measures
they created and adopted the local plan
which includes energy efficiency
stipulations to sustainability code
level 4 and also water regulations to
address our drought prone area
for example the planning policy for
developments in thanet specifically
state that houses must be designed to
use less than 110 liters per person
rather than the standard 125 liters
the planning department was able to add
the extra stipulation because we are in
a drought-prone area
they're also able to stipulate that all
developments greater than 10 units must
have ev charging points which means that
ev charging points will now be added as
standard
with regards to biodiversity they added
a biodiversity net gain policy where
developments must show that biodiversity
is being improved and not lost
this scheme is now being improved to
include 10 biodiversity net gain and the
mechanism of how this will work uk wide
is still being drawn up
our fleet donut electric are the largest
emission vehicles possible for a diesel
fleet and the team reduced the distance
of the routes traveled as much as
possible to further reduce the emissions
from diesel use over the past few years
the facilities team has installed led
lighting whenever the old lighting had
run its course
the lighting is also on a movement
sensor system which saves money and
greenhouse gas emissions
they've also removed plastic cups from
the offices and removed the coffee
vending machine encouraging staff to use
their own coffee mugs and water bottles
which has worked well
move on to paper use
staff and counselors are getting used to
google docs
some of us anyway
and working with documents on their
computer screens instead of always
printing them out
this is a saving on paper use first and
foremost however it is also saving on
the cost of printers and the cost of
clicks
for example
in 2013 to 2017 the council rented 25
printers at 786 pounds per printer
this cost the council 98 000 over five
years
there is a click charge per print which
came to 38 000 over five years
the cost of paper use in those years was
53 000 pounds
the total expenditure was 190 000 for
the five years
from 2017 the council rented just 13
printers at 495 each
paper use reduced to just 25 000 pounds
from 53 000 and the click charge was
reduced from to sixteen thousand from
thirty eight thousand
that means that the total cost of
printing and paper came to seventy six
thousand as opposed to a hundred and
ninety thousand for the previous five
years
the graph shows that even before the
pandemic the use of paper and printing
was reducing greatly as people were
using google docs to work on documents
instead of printing them out
moving on our communications team
created a climate change communication
plan and joined the kcc climate change
group for coordinated working
they've promoted the work of our
officers over the past few years for
example this climate change pledge
produced by a climate change officer
this pledge shows how the carbon
footprint of individuals is roughly
split into the food we eat the emissions
from our home the emissions from
travelling and the emissions from within
everything we purchase
it then goes on to suggest some things
that individuals can pledge to reduce
their carbon footprint such as
eating less meat reducing food waste
insulating your homes
walking or cycling or using public
transport instead of driving where
possible reducing flying reducing our
spending on new items
moving on to air quality and transport
than its air quality now meets all the
standards set by government which means
that it does not need to be
designated in air quality management
zone any longer
the inclusion of the ev charging points
within new developments has been a great
win for the team as well as the
institution of ev fast charges at
birchington and margate car parks
the local plan has included policies
which encourage developments to reduce
reliance on cars for example by being
situated within walking distance to
train stations or bus routes or with its
cycle paths included in their design
tdc employed a home energy on it a home
energy officer who has set up a system
where she can give advice to residents
and landlords on home energy efficiency
and also refer them on to relevant
groups
people can contact her by emailing the
address that's shown there or by filling
out a form on the agenda on the energy
sorry filling out a form on energy in
the home pages on our website she is
also working hard to draw down large
amounts of funding to retrofit
insulation and other low-carbon measures
in housing within thanet
she is also promoting the solar together
scheme which enables residents to
purchase solar pv at a cheaper price
tdc employed a climate change officer
with us tonight who now advises the
climate change cabinet advisory group as
well as the council on government
reports and the route to net zero
she also produces work such as climate
change pledge and gives talks to educate
councillors officers and members of the
public on climate change
she's been calculating the carbon
footprint of the council and working on
new net zero strategy and action plan
the first draft will be ready shortly
she will also write a tree and bio
diversity strategy for sanet
moving on to tree projects the climate
change officer has also gained funding
to engage the public in tree planting
activities
working with the charity trees for
cities she's run funding for a community
tree planting coordinator who will be
with us until next march and who will
run tree planting days with community
groups and schools in ramsgate
ramsgate was chosen because the area met
the criteria of the funding bid and
because margaret had already had over a
thousand trees planted by it we in the
past couple of years
these pictures show the first tree
planting day which was designated a
queen's canopy of queen's green canopy
event and attended by many tdc
councillors and residents
the top tree sorry the top right picture
shows our new tdc tree and bio
diversity action flag which will be used
at all tree and biodiversity events in
the future
by the end of this i'll probably be able
to say biodiversity never know
bottom left bottom left shows our open
spaces team helping to plant the trees
and our new community tree coordinator
anna ritchie water in the trees at the
bottom right there
moving to george v park
tdc worked with kcc on a sustainable
drainage system in a small green in
westbrook
the works mean water is stored and
filtered slowly through the planting to
remove any pollutants and help it drain
through the ground
before the upgrade the water would have
drained into the combined sewer network
which could be overwhelmed by heavy rain
and add to local flooding
this project has not only include
improved the surface water drainage for
margate but improved the overall
aesthetics and biodiversity of the area
so much so that people now come and sit
for a while to enjoy nature rather than
just run as brushing through it as they
did before
since the calling of the climate
emergency the council has also employed
a litter education officer she's worked
with schools to run
to create a litter picking and recycling
course for children and she's run
litter-picking days and community
activities
she also runs a sustainability forum for
local groups interested in litter
picking another environmental action
fanuc coast project with regards to
biodiversity the sanic coast project
kept going throughout the pandemic by
taking their seashore safaris online
greg one of their volunteers who is now
a tdc birdwise employee created a series
of films on the ecology of the coastline
and these were posted on our website
in 2021 they squeezed in twenty public
events and seven community events
engaging over five thousand people
tanek coast project volunteers also
spent over 1400 hours monitoring the
coast and reporting any incidents in
both years
the biodiversity and horticultural
officer created numerous wildfire
patches across the island
these can be found at tivoli park
margate which is the largest of the wild
flower meadow stretching the width of
the park
livington road at westgate
war memorial banks at westgate king
etherbert school in birchington ramsgate
cemetery in round state ramsgate arts
primary school ramsgate and st lawrence
churchyard ramsgate these have been
beautiful to look at as well as
providing food for pollinators
other areas for pollen pollinators have
been produced at fourness point and
westbrook undercliff in collaboration
with the bumblebee trust in 2020
moving on to bird wise project since
calling climate emergency we've employed
a number of bird wise officers to
protect the birds along our coastline
bird wise aims to ensure people can
enjoy the coast without disturbing the
birds that fly here from as far as the
arctic
so
we've done our bit it's your bit now can
you tell us what those birds are
come on
such top line starting at the left
any takers
it's a brent
goose how can you think that's a
canadian it's clearly a brent gush
next along
no
curl
next one
dunlin
next one golden plover
then the grey plover
and last on the top line of lap wing
bottom line oyster catcher
next one
purple sandpiper
red shank
ring plover
sandalin
and my favorite the turnstone
there turnstone well done let's hear it
for the turnstones
and that members is it so any questions
you've got i'm sure hannah will be able
to answer
and if not we'll make excuses and leave
quietly thank you
councillor david thank you very much
it's very entertaining as well as being
very informative uh members over to you
do you have any questions comments you'd
like to make yes please
thank you yes that was very interesting
um a couple of questions uh the first
one was about the litter education
officer now at one time we used to have
i don't know if it was a dedicated role
but i just remember hearing a talk by
them
someone that spoke about recycling in
particular now he didn't mention
recycling in that but what i think is
that to encourage more people to recycle
people need to really know
what they can recycle because there's
lots of myths that go around about you
know everything gets chucked out because
it's contaminated because someone's put
in something
i mean may not be a myth but what i'm
saying is people don't know exactly what
they can put in recycling and what they
can't so i wonder how much that is
covered by this post or if that post
could be developed more to include more
of that
and the second one was just about the
electric vehicle charging and
yeah it's great that we're bringing this
into new developments it's great we've
got a couple of public points is there
an actual plan to increase the
number of electric vehicle charging
points you know in public areas in
thanet thank you
i might be able to delegate these
questions to gavin
yeah hell of a girl yeah you're right in
terms of
we we did have about four or five years
ago
a waste and recycling education officer
unfortunately due to obviously financial
constraints we lost that post and then
we brought in the litter officer so the
litter officer does talk and and does
provide educational advice with regards
to waste and recycling i think from our
point of view it's
it would be disappointing after the
amount of work we've done that people
still don't realize what they can put in
the the recycling containers which ones
yeah and i think what we we're always
reiterating that message uh we do have
actually promotional
uh panels on the side of the refuge
truck should have seen the kobe message
and we're in the process of of rolling
out some new messages as well which will
also include recycling messages because
actually
uh for us those trucks visit every
street in the district at least once a
week so actually the opportunity to see
that message is is significant so we
utilize that in terms of the
yeah yeah yeah
thank you
because yeah i don't think it's
confusion about what goes in what
container i think it's more the detail
of it this is something i heard and you
can tell me if it's true or not but i
heard that you shouldn't put post-it
notes in recycling because of the very
weak glue on them now i don't know if
that's true or not but it's that kind of
thing that you know i just think it
would be really good to clear up for
people
you can put it in your recycling because
it goes through a process where it's
cleaned anywhere yeah
the electric vehicle obviously we're
working with the county because the
county the ones that predominantly get
the funding also putting pressure on the
government through
relevant bodies as well in terms of that
investment in the infrastructure
the government have made a significant
commitment to getting everybody to
electric cars by 2030 which is obviously
not that far away but we can't do that
without the the necessary infrastructure
and i know that there are uh lots of
collect uh sort of charging points at
some of the
services which is quite interesting
actually because i was at one of the
services a couple of months ago and
there were only tesla charges so unless
you had a tesla you couldn't charge your
vehicle which seems a bit a bit perverse
but we are working with the relevant
organizations and obviously when funding
becomes available we put in the relevant
charges in and also i think the issue is
uh supporting
local people and people who want to buy
electrical vehicles because i know i
don't know whether you wear but you
can't plug it into a normal
well you can plug it into a normal
electric socket it just takes up to 14
hours to charge your vehicle
but i know some of the manufacturers are
offering uh with the package of the car
to install a proper fast you know fast
charging unit as well so it's something
for us to consider
as we're looking for the smaller fleet
for electrical vehicles not the larger
fleet this moment in time but it is
something we will be considering the
future but we are looking at that option
even when we look at uh we're doing the
review of our uh
estate as well and when we review the
state the offices and the depots we need
to look at that infrastructure and that
future proofing requirement as well
thanks i've got three the first one's
for gavin and follows on from the from
the electric vehicles we've had offers
in the past of of of companies willing
to install
fast chargers for free are those sorts
of things no longer
available uh yes they are when they are
available we take up the offer but
there's always a catch
what sort of a catch i mean well
there's a
well
previously it's you you're making the
commitment so they're asking for further
commitment
as well but i would say in terms of
electric vehicles because this isn't
common knowledge yet is we are
uh trialing an electric refuge truck
next month so we've got a refuge truck
coming for a week and actually what i've
insisted is that we embed that into the
service so instead of it just doing
peripheral work it's actually going to
be doing uh some of the garden waste
collections because actually garden
waste collections are quite difficult
because the bins are really heavy so i
really get an opportunity to really test
test the vehicle
brilliant that's great may i move on to
my others chair
um so my second one was about with the
um
new developments new when we give
permission for new developments and
access to public transport because we
know this has been a real problem in in
some areas how much
maybe i'm not sure if there's anybody
here who's going to want to answer this
one but how much clout do we really have
to say to a developer we're sorry but
but this isn't going to work in such a
such a place because there's actually no
access to public transport at all and
everybody who's there is going to be
trapped unless they've got their own
vehicle um
yeah i mean i i think you're right there
is no one here that can answer that
fully
um i mean all i can say is that you know
through the revision of the local plan i
mean we are reinforcing you know green
credentials but you know there are going
to be logistical situations where we
can't necessarily say well you've got to
do this you've got to do that
um but we're certainly intending to make
things as green as we possibly can but
um i'll take that question back to the
planners and get a written answer thank
you that would be appreciated
and my last one was just following on
from the
hannah and i have just had
correspondence about this so it's just
asking for a bit more detail following
the the sad loss of our tree and
biodiversity officer i understand we've
got a consultant who's going to be
working with planning for a while on
tree matters what's the longer term plan
of that because obviously that was a
crucial post in terms of of protecting
those trees when we were looking at new
developments
i'm happy to answer that i mean we were
here to talk about what's happened so
far we're still reviewing the situation
as far as the
replacement of that officer is concerned
but crucially the funding that was there
for it will still be there and will be
utilized in some way
thank you members any more questions
thank you very much for the presentation
it's very very informative
um it was very sad to
go down to jackie baker's where we
planted that avenue of trees and
there are two missing on the right hand
side um is is that it is their money for
is there money to replace those trees or
is that it
thank you
yeah so unfortunately i think there's
only one that that we found is being
vandalized we had to take that
completely out um
there are another 58 trees um but we've
designated areas for that but perhaps we
could um use one of them to to go back
into jackie bakers if it's really if
that gap is really standing out like a
sore thumb such a shame because it looks
really good
yeah it's a shame
we can uh
from various members of ramsgate town
council we can find the money to buy
some more trees
to replace broken ones and things uh if
it's needed
lovely thank you
can i just add a comment to say that
that was really interesting and i'm
really impressed with the work that's
going on and i think
you know congratulations on whoever had
the foresight to think about employing
eve because
that work is going to be more and more
important as as uh prices go up and and
people are under more financial pressure
and i know she's doing a fabulous job so
thanks very much to everybody who's
involved in that
thank you members if there are no more
comments apart from for us
on behalf of all of us for me to thank
councillor baker for that report and dr
scott as well thank you very much for
your input this evening it was indeed
very very interesting i think it
probably caught quite a few of us by
surprise that just how much
difference some of the things have made
since
efforts
[Laughter]
thank you very much if you want to sneak
off now for an early pizza do please do
please do that
good night thank you very much
excuse me
okay
um as i hinted earlier on agenda item
number nine the supplementary agenda has
now been moved up the agenda so if i
could ask members to refer
to
that item
it is
of course the
winter gardens lease
call-in of an individual cabinet
member's decision
i hope you'll just permit me for these
extra couple of minutes
of introduction
um
for this call in it might be nice uh for
all of us uh and also i i should uh
welcome council elise uh first time
you've joined us this evening forgive me
for not welcoming you
earlier but for all of us but also for
the recording if we just run through the
process of the main issues that
uh were raised in your thinking so that
members thought well let's let us call
this in and and have it discussed so i'm
going to hand over to councillor huxley
police who's going to introduce uh it's
i believe mostly at paragraph 2 in the
report members
thanks chair
um this wasn't a decision taken lightly
to call it in
we discussed it
um the labour members and council austin
of the green party
so um obviously the workings of the
review and scrutiny committee
it's in the name isn't it it's to
scrutinize the workings of the council
and to have a very open and transparent
process so that we know
what's going on at the council so that
we can tell
residents businesses in the area why
we're doing what we're doing
and also for us as councillors too you
know so for our own decision making
processes as well
so obviously it says in the report
item 2.2
so we called it in in terms of item a
2.3 a the presumption of favor of
openness and transparency like i was
saying
and item f the need to give reasons and
explanations for the decision which we
didn't think
the officers had done
or the cabinet member
so it's really in the report here
so um probably the sort of two main
questions are
what are the additional costs
your ledger will incur by this decision
and not just to for a tdc to take the
lease back but what other costs will
be
a pile on on top of that and
um there was no attempt really to
quantify what the cost would be what the
detail of it
is um
we were wondering whether it was
something to do what what would uh
the um your leisure use the money for
that it wasn't specified was it for
example for staff redundancies
or supporting other parts of the your
ledger business
so and why should
tdc give that money back to your leisure
is it capital expenditure money is it
revenue money
so really what are the potential costs
associated with an early surrender the
lease
and again
another issue is what is the future use
of the winter gardens
so obviously other colleagues have got
questions as well so thanks
sure but thank you very much council
actually for outlining why we've called
it in to have a conversation and i do
know that uh
the jonah member of the public who's
with us is from a theater background
herself and has a good deal of
experience in how theaters and so on
work so she has a particular interest in
this subject so thank you for outlining
that for us
and uh i'd like now to call upon either
chris or matt
uh to provide some background on to the
decision and of course councillor reese
pugh as well
thank you chair matt's not here tonight
so you i'm afraid you've got me instead
i know i've
stealth we've removed his name clark no
he's not here i've done a bit of a swap
with him i was there explaining to
councillor bayford earlier cabinet next
week clashes with west ham's first
semi-final appearance in a european
competition in my lifetime
so
i shan't be here next week and matt is
covering me so here i am tonight so
a bit more
indeed indeed
um okay yeah it is indeed yeah um so
getting back to mata's uh at hand um
please excuse my digressions uh if i can
take you back to
january 2021
at that point in time we were
in the midst of the third national
lockdown and obviously the leisure
services in particular the leisure
sector had suffered um significant
financial damage
uh and strain as a result of covid
later in january that month there was a
report that was taken to cabinets a
cabinet considered
a number of recommendations that were
taken to it about how we could help your
leisure
with their ledger services
and the sustainability of their offer
over the short term and into the medium
term
sort of main
areas that consider the part of that
report were um
firstly the impact of covert on their
operations and a need for a loan of
between 700 to 1.700 000 to one point
five million pounds uh to date nothing
has been drawn down on that so that was
one of the items that was considered um
the
the second point was actually most
relevant to this uh decision was to
provide 230 000 pounds worth of funding
uh to the winter gardens to ensure it
could reopen and operate from october 21
which meant addressing the heating
issues they're particularly replacing
and relocating the boiler
and then
thirdly explore opportunities to
refinance existing your leisure loans
they're actually more attributed to the
leisure centers they've got those
discussions are ongoing with lloyd's the
bank to see if we can get better rates
it's been um quite a difficult uh and
run-ups process but um we're in a
situation now where they're more
interested in looking at refinancing
those loans
and then fourthly uh relevant to your
question council huxley is around what
the long-term
future were for the theater role and the
winter gardens uh and until looking look
at removing your ledger from those
arrangements
so it should also be noted in that
report when we're looking at the winter
gardens um there are a couple of key
things that are identified so three to
four million pounds worth of long-term
investment that was needed in this in
the um in the building at the winter
gardens um
for necessary repairs and improvements
um
in addition to that we kind of had on
our radar at that point in time the the
bidding that we were going to be putting
into the towns fund it's now become the
margate town deal
so that's a bit of background
where we are now and trying to answer
some of these questions
so your ledger had a lease to run the
winter gardens until uh october 2024
but in light of the financial pressures
that i mentioned and also us receiving
300 000 pounds as part of the margate
town deal to look at for the future of
the winter gardens it was decided that
was the right thing to return the winter
gardens to
tdc uh in order for us to begin to plan
what the long-term future and vision for
the venue would look like
in some normal circumstances we would
have taken this to a formal cabinet
meeting and sort of addressed this the
needs for transparency that have rightly
been sort of addressed by council huxley
but we needed to get a portfolio
decision pushed through relatively
quickly in order to allow uh your
leisure to approve the decision to to
end the lease early at their board
meeting on the 9th of march um following
these approvals um as such the the venue
will be returned to thailand district
council hands and operations from the
14th of august this year
turning to the sort of the cost that
your leisure are going to bear as part
really it's because they are ending that
lease early so they've got staffing
commitments that's estimated
in the region of 66 000 pounds
potentially for redundancy costs
associated with staffing and upwards of
73 000 pounds of pension costs as well
um
in addition to that outside of staffing
costs they were able to obtain about 17
000 pounds worth of crowdfunding um
which was to keep those venues open and
it's it's to be
to be determined whether that funding
will need to be returned to the donors
so once we've determined the best way to
fund those potential costs or at least
underwrite them was returning back to
that boiler issue because we'd
identified 230 000 pounds worth of
funding that we could use to um
address the boiler issues for the venue
to open october last year
but because we knew we were in a more a
short-term scenario we actually opted
for a temporary fix to the boiler
and that came at a cost of 63
which late leaves 167 000 pounds of
funding uncommitted and these are
revenue costs although the boiler works
would have been capital it was revenue
funding that would have been made
available for them um to do to do the
necessary works
um the other thing that i just want to
stress is
this is the maximum amount of money that
we are willing to provide your leisure
to meet these costs where we will
underwrite their costs up to that value
if they go in excess of that they will
bear those costs
but equally if they are less than that
we will only fund them up to the cost
that they will bear so there will be a
full
open book accounting arrangement whether
it be required to provide any
documentation supporting evidence in
order for us to verify the costs that
they've incurred
due to us
ending the lease early
thank you chair hopefully that's a
sufficient introduction to the item
thank you very much caterpillar did you
have anything you wanted to add from a
cabinet and portfolio holder point of
view
i did chair thank you um just to
add a bit more uh information
particularly i'm not going to go into
the technical side i think chris has
definitely covered that and
good luck to west ham uh for the the
night the night the cabinet meeting um
up the hammers is all i can say um i
think it's important to acknowledge that
chris and his team have worked
incredibly hard and particularly in
conjunction with your leisure to get to
this point it's not an easy decision to
make a cabinet member decision rather
than bring it through the correct
process
but as chris has already said because
there was a board meeting for your
leisure that was fast approaching and it
was deemed necessary to make this the
decision as it was doesn't mean i don't
welcome
now coming uh to the ovum scrutiny
committee uh to explain this that's
absolutely fine um you know i think it's
important to acknowledge that we do have
some funding available through the
margate town deal as chris has already
outlined and there is separate funding
for
the theater role because while i
appreciate that the agenda item says the
uh the winter gardens lease and it's
also the theater royal that is returning
back to tdc as well um so they're both
being separated from um
uh the the assets that we owned that
your leisure manage um and there's also
funding available within the market town
deal for the theatre royal as well uh
which of course um has its own set of
challenges um but i think it's
incredibly important to acknowledge that
that bookings are going to end
or cease towards i believe the beginning
of august with chris and for the winter
gardens for us to have plenty of time to
be able to do this study and and
everything um
to see what is best going forward for
the winter gardens so it made sense for
us to now
take hold of the lease rather than your
leisure continue to hold the lease on a
building that they can't use and that is
empty and that they can't then advertise
for events
so we want to be able to ensure that the
winter gardeners as i've said before
before is closed for the least amount of
time
so that we can uh understand and
appreciate and
finalize a long-term future for the
winter gardens that it could be up and
running again um as soon as possible um
i think it's also worth noting as well
as chris has said that you know this is
only as a result of the early surrender
of the lease and he will be capped at
this level
and as chris has already said it will be
signed off by him as section 151 officer
as well um so all of that will be as
always completely above board um but
yeah chair happy to take anyone's
questions really
thank you very much just this is a
really simple question for a simple guy
like me
um i'm imagining that
the long-term future of of the winter
gardens
um be affected by who actually held the
lease in other words stanley district
council couldn't have a major say in the
development of the theater if it was
leased to someone else
you know
so therefore
is it
more advantageous to then district
council to be able to oversee
the the redevelopment the improvements
if we hold the lease rather than if it's
held by someone else yeah thank you
chair that's a very good point um and i
always wince when you say uh a simple
question from a simple guy because i
think as we all know when you speak in
council it's never a it's never a simple
sentence that comes out of your mouth
chair in all due respect and i mean that
in the nicest possible way um
uh you know in short answer yes it does
i think that actually as i um myself and
our then director of property and our
director of regen uh did an interview
with i think it was kent messenger a few
months ago um because their worth is
from local residents that you know the
winter guns was just going to be sold
and it was going to be turned into flats
and all that kind of stuff so we did
that interview to to kind of reassure
residents that that wasn't the case and
i think what i would say is that by us
now taking back the lease as we already
own the the freehold um from a position
it certainly makes more sense really and
we have much more of a say and i think
in a sense as well the community has
more of a say because it would always be
difficult if um if we we conduct this
this study
and the suggestions or the
recommendations move away from what your
leisure have been running the winter
gardens as is particularly their
business model that would then be
potentially quite difficult really to
try and remedy between the two of them
and of course you know although we've
got three hundred thousand pounds
allocated for that study it would then
be a terrible waste if we're not then
able to implement those recommendations
because your leisure wanted to go in a
different direction so you know i think
this is
the best outcome
and i would say that is advantageous for
us as a council
thank you councillor huxley
thanks for that for these clarifications
just the question why wasn't that in the
report all those things that i've asked
and you've replied i know there's a
total time pressure
but
um and also could perhaps west ham
united could have fund the renovation of
the
as they got lots of taxpayers money and
cheap rent uh their grand
uh i couldn't possibly comment on the uh
the the operation of the london stadium
um
i think uh there were there was further
information that was provided to council
pew when he was making the decision um
but i think it's fair comment to say the
decision notice that was published was
was limited in terms of the amount of
information that was that was actually
published and that's that's fair comment
take that on board and something we'll
consider going forwards
chair
sorry
um it may be that actually i mean i can
work in conjunction with chris we could
probably put some of this information
councillor huxley into a document for
other scrutiny members i'm happy for
this information to be shared i'm sure
chris is as well so that you've got it
in
on paper really and you know something
for you to be able to refer back to
because i'm sure as this as as the
months go on and everything and as the
winter gardeners does then take no
bookings after august i'm sure we'll all
be receiving questions from from
residents so i'm sure that's something
that we're happy to work in conjunction
and supply to committee members
and keeping the public as informed as
possible as it goes along through
regular statements through the wave and
so on yeah okay thank you
uh thank you
there are some other councillors and
members um
it's ironical that we're not live
streaming tonight because i'm aware that
so many people are interested in this
subject um
i read the report thoroughly and i thank
chris sand councillor pugh for
what they've stated tonight
it has been said obviously we all know
the winter gardens is a massive asset to
margate
as the theatre role is um
also um
and i didn't declare an interest but i
think most of you know my interest in
those places uh over many many years
and i say joe public are watching us of
what we do tonight your leisure
um
i'm aware
since they took over and you know as
leisure force before that
um they're not in a good position
themselves anyway um i've followed those
over the years
purely out of interest that's what we're
here for
but i think what's in front of us
tonight
um
makes sense
um
i've often said that all right i can
recall the days when
summer seasons were in this town and
mark a borough council and you all know
i'm that old to remember that sort of
thing
um they never made money except for one
and that was in 1968
and chris would be interested in this it
was danny larue
you know you can laugh
he was good um with ronnie corbett the
show ran for 18 weeks
and this never happened again unless you
do miracles chris but
margate rate players were given money
back on their rates because it did so
well
i know that's a little bit off subject
but the report i think is good
it does make sense
to see your leisure go from these
entertainment venues and i know all
about the
sports things and i don't attend those
places but
it makes sense
the thana district council
shouldn't run theaters but on this
occasion we've got to do something and i
say tonight
joe public are watching us
because they want answers and thank you
for your report
council of the king then council rating
please
thank you
well my point echoes what councillor
tomlinson has just said in terms of the
public watching this decision very
carefully
i think one of the things that worries
people is that the building which
obviously does need a great deal of
investment will just go to rack and ruin
as other places in margate have and then
it will be lost because
it's just beyond repair and particularly
if the boiler only had a temporary fix
i'm worried about it for the coming
winter so is there assurances that it
will be maintained and we won't find it
flooded out or something in the middle
of winter
thank you
thank you council keem we'll obviously
be doing our um
our best to maintain the asset during
the period of time that it's not
operating which we want as council poo
said to be for as limited a time as
possible that will
largely involve officers going in for
spot checks on a on a regular basis to
you know make sure that the roof's not
gonna hold and water is pouring through
it and um the building is operating on a
uh well not operating it is in a
reasonable state um but yeah there are
um
there are processes that will be put in
place to make sure there are checks put
on building while it's in that sort of
vacant
period
i just wanted to add to that councillor
keane that you know as chris said that's
always a priority for us and no one
wants to see a building as wonderful as
the winter gardens decay and you know
falling into the sea god forbid but you
know there's certainly challenges with
the building i know that the entire
building itself is listed and that
includes the extension at the back that
i think was built in the 1970s is
included within that entire listing so
it's not just
the old kind of heritage areas of the
building that listed the entire thing is
so you know we've got to try and
maintain that as best we can and that
may be why your leisure has struggled
because it's a bit of a hodgepodge of
certain things and things have been
added and taken away and stuff like that
so it's certainly a priority for us but
i think that's why it's important we get
this study done as soon as possible and
i think it's coming to cabinet at the
end of this month to release the funding
so that can start or the process can
start because it's incredibly important
we get that done as soon as possible so
that we can then decide on a long-term
future for the winter gardens and and
progress that forward really because i
think as chris already said in his um
response you know we're looking at three
to four million pounds worth of
refurbishment on the building alone you
know it needs a considerable amount of
investment and no one wants to see it
you know decay and going to ruin and go
beyond repair really so i think that's
why we're doing this now because you
know i don't want to be coming back
years from now you know and saying look
it's too late you know we can't do
anything because i think you know
residents
will not only be be angry but counselors
will be angry and everyone that has
former memories of that building won't
particularly accept that we've done all
we could to
to you know
make it make it the best it can be
just uh two short questions uh first one
do we know any rough ideas of the the
time scale for the feasibility study
and set
and and secondly obviously the building
is going to be closed for you know
a bit a bit of time will there be any
obviously because of it being empty um
and i've been in the area where
people you know teenagers that could
break in will there be any security uh
covering that site
uh so in response to your first question
uh the study itself um i'll seek an
update from our director of regeneration
i'll get back to all committee members
on that uh because i'm not aware of the
time scales for that myself um on your
second question counselor vatican i
think it's it's incredibly important
that the building is less secure and we
know what kids can be like and
everything um so that is a priority for
us um so i'll certainly look into that
with officers um
it was certainly muted a couple weeks
ago during discussions with officers
about finding maybe a meanwhile use for
the building so that it's not just
locked up um whether we can or not in
the interim um we'll have to wait and
see but i know that there are you know
clubs locally that are looking for
spaces to use and stuff like that so if
we can i think that would be great
because it just means that you know you
have the kind of the watching eyes and
and everything and it's not step vacant
and then it's used as a as a place for
teenagers to hide and
you know
yeah so it just helps and you know it
the younger younger people will have
less few places to hide in the dark and
smoke without their parents or anyone
seeing them um so yeah
okay um yeah thanks to both of you
report um you have answered
my questions really just the the one for
clarification i've been asked why um the
winter gardens was being closed in
august the 14th
uh when people consider that as a peak
season i think you did mention um the
reason but could you just clarify that
with me once again thank you
sure um
my understanding is but i will get this
clarified my understanding is so that we
can commence with the work
um of the feasibility study um and
and and to really look at what the long
term future is of the venue but
i don't know
that that was the reason to break the
lease i can't comment on exactly why the
date was but i will um get a firm answer
on that and come back to you
yeah yeah yeah
so sorry council curry i can oh i'm
gonna move
i can i can come back and provide some
clarity on that so the date of that
august was agreed in conjunction with
your leisure um quite a while ago i
believe over a year ago um to give them
time to
to provide you know because they have
bookings that are booked up years in
advance and everything like that so it
was agreed as a as a date to kind of you
know put down the marker and that any
events before that could be held but
couldn't after so that we could commence
the feasibility study because i think
the priority was um
shared not just by officers but the
cabinet at the time um
and the decision makers was that we
wanted to give your leisure as much
notice as possible and not potentially
cut them off too soon and then they'd
miss out local people would miss out
events and
tickets would be cancelled and events
would be cancelled and stuff like that
so it was just to kind of provide enough
of a buffer for the long-term planning
to um to occur
yeah thank you chair uh just a quick
question so um needs three to four
million pounds of the refurbishment
which could be five to six once you get
going um what's the plans for that money
so that's obviously the opening
reopening is going to based on when
those funds are available
so thank you castle fellows we'll have
to see what the feasibility study says
particularly for the recommendations for
the long-term use of the building
because i think that may open up
opportunities for us to seek
a partner from the private sector uh to
assist us in not only renovating the
building but then potentially running it
with an operator or something like that
um
i think that that would that would then
help i don't think it's necessarily
within the council's interest to fund
the entire renovation on our own i don't
think it's what we do best i don't think
as a council i don't think we run
theaters very well that's just an
opinion really um you know residents may
want me to get up on stage and sing a
michael buble song but i don't actually
think they pay tickets for it so you
know council thomas and his agreeing as
well it's certainly one um so i think
that's i think that's part of part of it
really is that we need to seek a
particular commercial partner uh that
will maybe cover the costs or assist
with some of the costs and you know and
i think that's what's more important is
that we find a long-term operator for
the building that will take it forward
in the future
thank you chair thanks for letting me
come back um the dates which um if you
can tell me to go away
the reason that they
yeah the date was set
and this comes from the manager
the week before is the sole weekend
which the winter gardens is used more
now
and that takes a fortune
so
hence
as i understand it
that's why they came a week to clear up
and that's why they're shutting then
are you intending to build it up at all
that is a
worry and if i come just one other item
then i will shut up
um i have said this at meetings before
uh the previous managing director
had plans through
english heritage or whatever it's called
now
for the winter gardens
when things weren't looking too good
uh this removed the roof off what's the
queen's hall which was the sixes that
was put on
uh english heritage were very very
interested in copping up some money
because it was going to be brought back
into its former glory now we all know
we've had co we'd come in we've got to
change management at the winter gardens
but those plans are in this building
somewhere
and i think gavin's heard me say this
before sorry gavin um
but start searching because they were
brilliant but
folding up is a worry because we've seen
what happens
when you ball buildings up
thank you i'll keep quiet in our chair
thank you council thompson never i would
never expect you to be quiet um
particularly about margaery um
i mean it's a very good point i mean
that's something i'll have to check and
get back to you and the rest of the
committee um i don't think it's
particularly interesting to board it up
i think visually that sends the wrong
message really particularly to the
community
and i think as i said explained before
if we find a meanwhile use for the
building then it won't necessarily need
to be
boarded up
essentially and i think that that would
be
wonderful because if it can have a
temporary use and still be used then you
know that
will mean that it won't necessitate that
of course it's important that we secure
the building anyway um
so that's something that we'll be
working
um
closely on and i'm happy to make a
priority um
going back to your question again about
taking the roof off was it the queen's
hall was it
the queen's hall used to be known as the
sun lounge that was an open space
uh that was like it when it was built
and that was before i was born into 1911
uh but but the savior's brought back to
as it was because the need of the
queen's hall
isn't
what it used to be with all the big
dinners and everything else that's all
changed
uh it's put there you know cabaret
nights and so on but life and
entertainment as we all know has been
changed so
yeah
take the roof off but it's not of course
as easy just to take the roof off
yeah i mean what i would say to that
counselor thomas and if there are plans
um and if that has been muted before
then you know that may potentially come
up in the feasibility study for a future
use of it i mean part part of that site
to be kind of open air and and stuff
like that and the concerts you could
have and everything would be fantastic
um so of course i'm sure that will will
come up in the study but um if there's
any if you have any more information
about that please send that to me
because i'm more than happy to then
facilitate that and see if that may be
something that can be
implemented into the into the study of
course i'm not the expert so if the
experts look at it and think it's not a
good idea then fine but i'm more than
happy to ensure that we we put that on
their radar
yes thank you chair um
i just really wanted to ask um in the in
this period of where it's not being used
have we liaised with other organizations
outside
um
customers whatever you want to call them
like the fire authority
um
the winter gardens is a special risk i
know that because i
sit with my firefighters hat on at the
moment
um and obviously it's an open space
which causes problems for firefighting
um if it's unoccupied there's always a
worry that people go in rough sleepers
they break in
they do things it might be advisable
maybe to bring them on board just to up
their their pda
their predetermined attendance and just
make them aware um what's going on
because obviously we don't want to lose
the winter gardens
but we would like to get in there quick
if there was an issue so that's just me
speaking
personally um i don't know if you
thought about that but it might be
advantageous thank you
i mean councillor mall thank you for
that i think that's a great suggestion
um i'm not aware of if we've had those
discussions or not though i can check
with officers uh but whether we have or
not i think that's a very important
point um and that's definitely something
that we can we can look into so yeah
thank you
if i could just add to that um
not just for the winter gardens but for
our vacant properties there's certain
conditions we have to meet or
obligations of our insurers um because
obviously this asset has a valley to us
and we'll be liaising with our insurance
as one of those sort of parties as well
as the other sort of bodies as well that
you've mentioned uh uh ones that we
consider speaking to but our insurers
will set out certain the frequency of
visits the building the security that
needs to be in place
um
and any other sort of measures to
protect the asset
yeah the main reason just for for
mentioning is obviously
i serve at canterbury and we've had a
lot of major shops in canterbury that
have gone
and that caused a magnitude of problems
with vagrants rough sleepers
criminal damage anti-social behavior
all of that will come into the mix i'm
sure
but if we if we hit it in the right
context and we have the right people
there we have our security that sort of
thing looking after it then obviously we
should mitigate that to a minimum so
just for reason for mentioning it thank
you
thank you very much for all those
comments and points members um
simple question from a simple guy
um
so tdc let's say has wrestled the lease
back under its control and it earns the
freehold
broadly speaking there it seems to me
there are two ways you could rescue this
building
you could crowdfund in small chunks
even though for some of the stars who
made their careers in that place a small
chunk could be ten thousand pounds or so
um and they might be offered a named
seat somewhere in the theater so you
could raise a fair bit of money
from
stars of the past and presents on to
people who have an interest in doing
that
an alternative route would be to find a
sugar daddy someone like uh
um
good grief his name just got him
um
um he the theater all he shot the
theater royal in dreary lane for almost
two years
in order to fully gut and refurbish that
building this is a man he writes for
musicals his name is
weber thank you very much andrew lloyd
webber
a 20 million pound investment in a
building like that to him would be small
change is the council at any point do
you think you don't have to answer
tonight but
is there any mileage in the council
seeking a serious investor someone who
loves the theater who loves performance
and if you've seen what he's just done
to jury lane
and he did it with his pocket change
really because he could afford to close
it and keep a lot of the staff close by
um
i realized they're very simplistic ideas
either small amounts of funding or a
huge funding from someone who would
require a bigger slice of the pie
afterwards of course but is that
anywhere in the council's thinking
instead of doing the building piecemeal
shut it gut it rebuild it
yeah thank you chair and that certainly
wasn't a simple question but don't worry
um
uh
i completely agree what i would say is
that we're keeping all options open so i
think that's really important i don't
think it's a good idea for us to
restrict any possibilities for funding
crowdfunding or anything else
for the the future of the winter gardens
um i mean the idea of a name seat in
plaques is a great idea um i think it'd
be great if the mayor of margate had a
name plaque
well you know you could you
i mean the mayor of margate could pay
for a gold seat chair um if they wanted
to um but anyway um
on the on the question of sugar daddies
i i i don't know as many as you do chair
i'm afraid um you know the council
thomas might be one i don't know um
sadly he's not mine um but no we're
looking at all options and we're happy
to um to try and do that and
particularly if there is a um a great
theater great of the theater and
entertainment uh we'd like to come along
and help support it in that way i mean
that would be wonderful really because i
think as councillor thomas and said
we've had so many great people come and
perform here not just in years gone by
but recently as well you know i've been
there for many gigs and many shows and
comedians and you know i'm sure that you
know hopefully we can build up a bit of
a consensus and a a group of well-known
names that want to help us
bring this building into the 21st
century and have a long-term future
thank you very much were there any
specific proposals that any of the
members wanted to bring
i think there's been an agreement
already that
uh we can be given more of this detail
in in writing
um and the other thing i mentioned was
the possibility of regular updates
for the public through the
uh information uh press releases and
things
if we can work along that i'm sure it
will go
some way to helping counsellors to
answer members of the public who come
with questions if they feel it's it's
all gone a bit quiet
but thank you very very much thank you
for calling us in thank you very much
for coming
and speaking to us on this subject it
clearly interests a great number of
people and so thank you for all of that
um
i don't know whether you would like to
leave now uh or stay for the rest of the
meeting it's entirely up to you we can
take a a moments break
while
while you pack up and go if you like yes
thank you very much indeed
a gender item uh the next agenda item
then is the budget monitoring report
it's the third report for 21.22
mr blundell please
thank you chair um
during my time here this is the first
time that we brought budget monitoring
to
overview and scrutiny
i think it's it's an important thing for
the committee the panel to committer uh
consider in order to
improve the overall level of financial
awareness of members in the authority
and and um
for the purposes as council huxley was
saying for us to demonstrate sort of
transparency of our financial position
so this report went to cabinets back in
march
um sets out our quarter three positions
so three quarters of the way through the
current financial year
of our financial position on both the
general fund revenue budgets general
fund capital and the same for the hra
so the the overall headlines from this
report if you look at table one
uh just below section 1.4 we'll show you
there's just shy of a two million pound
overspend forecast for our general fund
revenue spending for this financial year
we are now beyond the the end of the
financial year but my team are working a
way to close the
2122 financial accounts we'll probably
have
sort of indicative figures for that in a
month's time and hopefully be able to
report something to cabinet in june um
because obviously there is quite an
involved process to to actually close
the financial account so this gives us
as of december where we think or where
we thought we were going to land so you
see a 2 million pound overspend
beyond that in section two there's a
breakdown and i'll just whittle through
some of the the key uh items there
so you'll see the first one is is
housing needs that's largely temporary
accommodation of 444
thousand pound overspend it's worth
noting that this has been considered and
accommodated in the
2223 budget so we put an additional 400
000 pounds into the budget for next year
so that should contain
that budget
overspend to a certain extent obviously
it's it still remains to be seen
how the cost of living crisis will play
out next year and that remains a risk
for us and and certainly the amount of
expenditure we will face in terms of
temporary accommodation
moving
further on we'll see there's some income
shortfalls within uh property building
control
and land charges that have been there
for some time
50 000 within building control has been
recognized in the 2223
budget there's also action that's been
taken within the property estate to
start
rent reviews and i like to try and
increase rental levels there
some of the other key overspends we've
already heard about your leisure um
previously
the 160 000 pound there relates to some
of the the pressures they've been facing
as a result of covid that's also been
reflected in next year's budgets part of
the growth additional resources we put
into it
you'll see additional audit fees of 37
000 pounds that's in relation to uh
additional charges from grant thornton
in relation to the work they were doing
on the statutory recommendations
other key overspend or income shortfall
so
domestic waste collection so within
gavin's area
there's been a requirement to run two
additional waste collection rounds have
been
manned by uh or resourced by agency
staff
in order to keep the service running
during the pandemic and those
those two additional rounds have now
been incorporated into next year's
budget as well
as par as permanent growth into the
budget so that's overspend should be
accommodated on next year's
budget
you'll see income shortfalls within the
port and harbour area again that's
largely covered related
and then uh crematorium income is is
forecast to be down as well we were
actually up last year which is one of
the
um
obviously the unwelcome uh from a
service perspective
aspect of the pandemic but it did bring
in more income due to higher death rates
but we've seen a reduction this year um
in the amount of income that the
crematorium has brought in
there's then some items
that don't have actual financial figures
attach them in relation to council tax
and business rates because they don't
get charged to the council taxpayer in
year but you'll see within the text that
business rates in particular is a real
risk for us will probably be down by the
region of about
a half a million pound we'll be using
our equalization reserves to fund that
at year end
um similarly on council tax
we're usually
positive that we can recover council tax
but there's obviously not been a huge
amount of collection activity um or debt
recovery activity
and because of the pandemic we've not
been using bailiffs and the like to the
same extent that we would do
in usual times so our debts and arrears
have have increased compared to normal
times
so looking at it in the rounds two
million pound overspend we should be
able to fund that from one million
pounds worth of the covered reserves
that we held back last year so you may
remember it september
uh try and get my years right september
21 i think it was we allocated three
million pounds worth of reserves um for
uh covered related pressures there's
still one million pound of that um still
available so we'll use that this year
and we also got one million pounds worth
of emergency funding uh in this year
related to covid so that largely covers
our forecast gap obviously is a forecast
and things could change depending what
happens with the actual year-round
position but that's uh it looks
manageable the position at the moment of
time
moving on to section 5 the general fund
capital program
it's looking like it's going to be
underspent by about 35 million pounds
which is huge sounds like a huge figure
that is largely due to us adding the
margate
leveling up and ramsgate leveling up
funds the capital programme in full so
you see there's about 25 million pound
of that on forecast under spend it's
just related to those two schemes and as
we've got better information on the
phasing of those schemes the money will
be slipped into later years so it's
really just a timing issue
we're not expecting to underspend
against those projects
uh actual project aside from those the
the main schemes in our capital program
that look like underspending are uh
public toilet refurbishment and office
accommodations of three quarters of a
million and three million
uh
respectively both of those schemes are
underpinned by us actually selling
related assets so
for in order for us to spend money on
public toilet refurbishment that was
predicated on us actually selling
existing public toilets to generate
capital receipts to invest in the ones
were left over we've not
disposed sufficient number of of toilets
well have not been any such disposals
and therefore no capital receipts and
therefore no spends which is why that is
uh in that position
very similar office accommodation
plans to spend money on our office
accommodation and potential move is
linked to selling this site this
building that we're in now obviously
we've not sold as we're still here
and therefore there's been no
significant spend against that project
um
looking at their housing revenue
accounts
um
this is largely on budget so there's a
very small underspent of a by relatively
small underspender of a quarter of a
million pounds uh albeit it's worth
noting that that is against the budget
so um the budget
is
to
to have a deficit of two million pounds
so we will be just having a smaller
deficit so when i say we are
underspending what that really means is
we've just got a smaller deficit
and similarly on the capital program it
is looking like it's going to be
underspent um so
only about half the budget been spent by
the end of december that is a big
improvement actually it's worth noting
where we were when the service was
provided by east kent housing i think
there's been a number of legacy issues
that have been um sort of
adopted by the tenant and leaseholder
services
that they've they're having to work
their way through that
and the the biggest area that we're
looking at is the tower block works but
obviously that's a long-term program
that similar to the market town deal
those projects will just be slipped and
phased forward it's not that those
projects won't go forward
so
that's the just the summary i wanted to
bring to ons tonight and happy to take
any questions on the content of the
report or otherwise
thank you very much chris members yes
councillor huxley
[Music]
thanks chris
um
uh item 7.4
um
sorry regiment um amounts of 650
368 000 are budgeted for market
intervention and acquisition programs
these budgets are currently soon to be
spent by the 31st of march
but are dependent on suitable sites
coming onto the market for purchase
um i've we've had lots of discussions in
east clifton central hub about
empty plots of land and empty properties
that ttc could take over we had a site
visit with bob porter
a couple of months ago
so is that somewhere that we could spend
that money in ramsgate thank you
i'm not too sure i'm afraid cancer hurts
i wouldn't want to give you a definitive
answer i would i would expect the marga
intervention monies are our ring fence
just for expenditure in margate but the
other acquisition programs i can't see
why they could not be because they're
just linked to bringing additional stock
into our housing revenue account so um
but i can get a definitive answer from
mr porter on that one
and just come back on that because
obviously the um particularly margate
the house prices have gone up it's one
of the highest nationally but in
ramsgate's not quite as high so
bob porter was saying that it's probably
better that tdc invests some money in
ramsgate because you'll get more for
your money as it were
okay thanks
and uh
the coastal waste scrutiny review
working party has concluded the
investigations
uh for the work that this panel uh
assigned them and i'm going to call on
councillor fellows to present his
findings but first
council bailly did you want to speak
before council's first presents or
afterwards which would you prefer
perhaps we'll hear from you first then
council bailey okay thank you very much
um
really i just wanted to speak in general
um support of this report i actually
thought the report itself was um
really clear and comprehensive and i
feel it could be um held up as a model
for future um scrutinies that's really
good
um as a ward councillor of a very uh
popular coastal area in viking bay this
area has particular significance to me
and especially to my residents and i i
welcome the recommendations
and while reluctantly acknowledging the
resource and logistical limitations of
the brief i do feel that recommendations
could even go further
the waste collection service more than
more than anything needs to be flexible
proactive and well manned
the british weather as we know is very
unpredictable and
an unexpectedly warm dane could bring
swarms of people to our coastline even
out of season
resulting as in us being caught out with
unfortunate residual waste
and while the message to take your
rubbish home may hit home with some
responsible visitors many do not behave
that way and expect the provision of
bins
seasons are becoming more extended it
seems and we now see many more visitors
than we used to in the spring and autumn
so maybe there needs to be a
re-evaluation of timings and
expectations and resourcing to reflect
that as well
self-monitoring bins sound great but
only if we have resources to deal with
them quickly and effectively and my
concern with these is that
um
it may be a bit of a piecemeal
collection which could which may not be
cost effective if you're going to pick
one being up from one area and one from
another
um one of our main problems as i
understand it well is is the accumulated
waste left overnight which blights our
other white otherwise scenic area
this waste is then subject to all the
elements and wildlife scattering all
around causing environmental problems
and causing even more work for the crews
to come to clear up in the morning
my understanding is that this problem is
due to the waste transfer station at
herdstone being closed early in the
evening
so we can't get rid of that last
lot of rubbish
so what we can do about that i don't
know
the only thing i can think of is maybe
to have um an allocated overnight
holding area somewhere
what i really would like to applaud
though is the recognition of our
valuable volunteer litter pickers and
the emphasis on working together with
the council
other authorities like dover do
celebrate their local environment heroes
and i feel this will go a long way to
towards showing our appreciation
and further to this i would like to
suggest that the council provides
dedicated litter backs for volunteers
maybe in a different color from the
usual than council bags with a volunteer
litipit clearly emblazoned on them
this would identify the litter pickers
as being volunteers and would be easily
recognizable and quantifiable maybe when
left out for collection
so i want to say but i really thought
the report was very good thank you
thank you very much councillor bailly
i'm sure you've already touched on then
some of the things that council of
fellows is going to be uh bring to us
but if i can hand over to you now then
please can't suppose to share your
report with us
uh thank you chair uh at the meeting on
26th of august 2021 the panel set up a
five-minute member coastal waste review
working party to
conduct a scrutiny review of the coastal
waste collection practices in our
district district
to review the topic
the review topic was picked out of a
list of topics that were identified by
the panel and the list forms part of an
overview and scrutiny panel work program
the working party was given specific
terms of reference which was as follows
a to review how the council ensures that
its promenades and beaches are kept
clear of rubbish and litter and make any
recommendations that the panel feel will
improve the service and b to review the
current replacement waste and dog
poo bin process at the district council
and make any recommendations that the
panel feel will improve that service
the committee should all have had a copy
of the review sent to them with this
evening's agenda and i hope you've all
had a chance to read it or we'll read it
in due course
we have conducted a thorough review of
coastal waste and i've come up with 20
recommendations the recommendations are
all listed in the review and include
such things as promoting senate as a
plastic free district more integrated
working with town and parish councils
and more appreciation of our volunteer
groups and litter pickers plus many more
it's been a really interesting exercise
to get an insight into the mammoth tasks
and efforts that the council staff and
many volunteers undertake to keep our
coastal areas clean and tidy year after
year
and keeping it attractive for both our
local residents and visitors of it to
our district
i'd like to add my thanks to the working
group
members
council thomas and councillor retingen
council keen and councillor austin it
was a real cross-party effort
and
and i'd also like to send my thanks to
nick and charles who facilitated the
review and all the meetings that we had
i'm sure we all found it very
interesting albeit a little bit
challenging through the omnicom wave to
organise everything virtually i think
we're quite proud of the document and i
sincerely hope the recommendations we
have made can successfully implement it
and i look forward to working with the
council officers and cabinet members to
see that they are
but only time will tell
i'm happy to take questions
thank you very much council fellows it
is really uh it bears repeating it is
really well set out so it's fairly
simple to follow the recommendations
that the paneling on behalf of the whole
committee i'd like to thank the panel as
well for the efforts that have been
uh put in um i'd only just like to talk
to most of it is self-explanatory what
you mentioned there but i would like to
mention it was really good to read about
the evidence you gain from terrish
tarish town and parish councils
because
it's one of the areas there have been a
number of other areas discussed at
various town councils i know we have at
ramsgate discuss ways in which the
councils can cooperate and work together
better and certainly it would seem uh
the litter on the streets keeping the
the place in which we live clean and
tidy using volunteers as well as others
to do that is uh
it was good that you gathered that
information as part of the work uh that
you were doing thank you so thank you
very much for that uh members do you
have any comments or questions you'd
like to make
of cancerverse
yes cancer curry please
um first of all thanks to members and
officers
review it's very interesting and lots of
good recommendations i can't really pick
out any that i don't agree with
20 recommendations whether we can
implement all of them is another matter
but certainly if we can implement most
of them it would really be a big
improvement particularly like the the
the idea about liaising with
volunteer groups uh really important
they do such a great fantastic job and
there's some good ideas in here
i particularly um like um
number six
tvc should consider approaching
voluntary litter groups
first when recruiting extra seasonal
staff i think this is a great idea and
really shows our appreciation and there
are some
incredibly hard-working volunteers
i suppose the most challenging um
uh
recommendation would probably be a
plastic-free regime i imagine that would
be a a great idea but
very challenging to put into uh
motion yeah thanks very much
yes please too yeah i mean volunteer
groups i mean yeah they're an untapped
workforce though
then we had them here we had i can't
remember there was about 20 of them came
came here and you know they they do feel
underappreciated they you know they they
said nobody can tdc ever contacts them
and says thank you to them on a regular
basis you know they go out day after day
you know just picking that up with their
own backs nobody asks them to do it you
know their untapped workforce so if we
can appreciate them in some way even
giving them a seasonal job someone you
know people you know go out and do it
for nothing and you get to end up
getting a paid job i think it'd be a
great thing and the plastic three thing
i think you know if you only go down any
harbour or you see the pubs dishing out
beer in plastic cups i mean if we can
stop that you know it's just it's just
any small thing that we can we can
recommend and we can work with
businesses to just to to do
you know can make a a big difference so
counter arshin councilmoor is it not
right that broadstairs is planning a
plastic free broad stairs did i hear
that from somewhere
oh yes that is correct
you'd have to speak to councillor ghana
because he's heading that
council
thanks um it's an amazing report
congratulations a lot of works gone into
it i'm just on the fly tipping reporting
form on the tdc website it's very clunky
and long-winded
um and there's no similar form for
reporting litter
so we're trying to get our residents to
report flights to being litter and
everything is there some way that we can
make it
um easier to use you talk in your
reports about an app
and they fix my streak but i think in
some ways yes fixed on street but also i
think tdc the website and that should
have
it should be updated i think that's
something actually that the
communications team were going to look
into
so i don't know if that's something you
could add to the report was a comment or
sorry and then just one other thing um
yeah but it's a really good idea about
the getting rid of take away pulsaring
cups and boxes and chip packets and
things but how do we actually
how do we actually um
deliver that i'm not sure if you can do
it as a by-law i think that's about
today
licensing i'm not sure if you can do
that with
with with um
cafes and places that actually already
have a license unless you're going to do
as a fan wide thing
um how is that going to be delivered
um i know this is saying other places
have
done this i've implemented this idea
so but um is the pspo legislation is
that that's one way that you can do it
thanks
thank you thank you
yes i would say in terms of excuse me
in terms of the app and this is a
conversation about today actually is
we did have an app
that
wasn't being supported we weren't aware
it wasn't being supported at the time
and people were using it and we had
several hundred people using the app but
it wasn't it hadn't been supported and
the decision was made by the digital
team that they wanted to move to a
different platform and we've moved to
that platform and that
obviously needs some work because really
it was the opportunity to to report that
online and then to go through our
digital system and then come out we've
got the incap technology we're just
fitting all the technology to all the
supervisors van so they'll get real-time
information we should link back into
those back office functions so we should
see that improvement in terms of uh
shops selling uh packaging cardboard
you know the chip packets rather than
paper and plastic cups
i'm not aware that there's anything we
can use specifically it's it's about
buy your power isn't it if if people
putting that pressure on those companies
and also ourselves and one of the issues
we have and and you'll be well aware is
uh where the worst is somebody goes into
a a
a chip shop and buys a big box and then
obviously walks out into the street and
then just fills all the street litter
bins with these big boxes which actually
aren't really that contaminated either
they can probably be reused if you just
put a sleeve in them and these are the
conversations that we've had with some
of the larger
fish
fish and chip shops it's just that
commitment and and like i said that that
pressure and really trying to
it's sort of an embarrassment factor
isn't it is them making a commitment i
think one of the things we can consider
is is a pledge and i know lots of lots
of other coastal terms do it where you
do a pledge to our environmental
credentials and actually start putting
stickers in shops that we're committed
to that pledge and that's quite an
effective tool that i've used previously
so it's something we can look at i would
say in terms of volunteers
i think personally as we do a lot of
work with volunteers we've had some of
the forums go in and we provide a lot of
support in terms of equipment to
volunteers across all the districts and
i think in terms of this report i accept
the recommendations i think we're happy
to take some of these recommendations on
uh some of the recommendations we've
done previously and i'm happy to to
explore them again but in terms of some
of the one of the things i think is
missing from this report is the the work
that the fanuc coastal project do
because obviously turner does a lot of
work with community groups and lots of
those community groups he has up to 500
volunteers across the whole of the
summer season doing a range of
activities across the coastline
including litter picking as well but i
think i think it's important i think in
terms of the way we're working the
positive for us and you you'll know that
i've i've been saying we've got a
transition and part of that transition
is we're bringing in multi-functional
teams so we've got these five
environmental operatives we're just in
the process of recruiting another seven
so we'll have 12 environmental
operatives and this is a new way of
working for us so these are the guys
that are trained on all the equipment
we've got and we've been using them
effectively doing deep cleans going into
areas where we've got problems when we
do the walkabouts we're going to start
doing that because i know we haven't
done a walk out of everybody it's going
to take a while for us to do it but
we're doing it with ward councillors and
then bringing in some members of those
teams to actually do that activity and
it's a very effective tool because these
guys are integrated into the cleansing
off park services they stand alone so it
just gives us that additional capacity
but i think i think it's a good report
and i'm having to say those
recommendations i think we just need to
formulate it into more of a structured
action plan where where obviously
yourselves can then monitor us against
some of that performance
consortium
it's great to to hear you that you
accept the recommendations governor and
i think uh you know an action plan would
be a sensible way to follow this up i
think the things that we felt as a as a
working party were that the the most
crucial recommendations were the first
two which is obviously prioritize this
in the budget which isn't you know which
i'm sure you'd be you'd be supporting us
on but something else has to go unless
we can raise more funds or unless we can
raise more resource and the other
recommendations are mostly about how we
might get the rest of that resource
whether it's working better with town
and parish councils whether it's working
better with volunteers whether it's
stopping literate source as some
councils already do
etc so there's a whole series of other
things and the business about the app
the last recommendation the fix my
street of i've gone down the street on
my way to a meeting reporting something
on the fix my street app on my phone as
i went i cannot do that with the fanuc
council website by any stretch of the
imagination and everybody we spoke to
the town and parish councils the
volunteers everybody all went please can
we have fix my street back it worked so
brilliantly we were so happy with it it
was so easy to use they're the people
who are committed to make to doing that
reporting which is doing part of our job
for us so i really strongly recommend
that we've that we reconsider that app
thanks
sorry i left the mic on uh council
fellows then uh thank you again very
much for that i wonder if uh given that
it is so well laid out um
mr hughes is going to come to us in a
moment and give us an idea of what
happens next in terms of the comments
from uh mr waite but uh could i ask you
then to propose that the report is given
uh to council and perhaps another member
of your
working party to second
the proposal
thank you very much i'm sorry
thank you very much uh it's it's a great
report thank you very much members we
agreed that we passed this on for the
next stage and we'll hear from mr hughes
then on what happens next we agreed
thank you very much mr hughes please
thank you chairman so just to just to
clarify the process that the report is
now going to go through which and
reflecting the points that gavin made
which is that obviously now that the
panel has recommended on accepted report
and recommended it onto cabinet uh
cabinet will now look at the report and
consider each of the 20 recommendations
and they will then agree or disagree
with those recommendations and adopt
some or all of those recommendations and
it's at that point that as gavin said is
at that point we create the action plan
based on the recommendations that have
been agreed
and then the panel can then look at the
agreed action plan from cabinet and
monitor that as opposed to monitoring
the entire report because again as i say
at the moment they're just
recommendations um it's up to cabinet as
to which ones of those they want to
actually take on board
yes mum
at the risk of saying the same again i
think it's important that we stress that
the recommendations some of them are
interdependent so we suggest this
because you could get the resource from
there so can we is there a way that we
can stress that to cabinet without and
we're not saying you have to accept them
all or not but on the other hand we do
have suggestions as to how resource
might be found so
yeah i mean i think that's probably the
best one by council fellows coming along
to the the cabinet the cabinet meeting
when it's
um presented and obviously if members
then want to speak under 20.1 at that
cabinet meeting they can do so and make
those points
so um
thank you chairman so just um we have
had a suggestion um uh from uh the chief
executive uh as a potential scrutiny
topic
and that is um
the uh how to improve and maximize
the relationships between town and
parish councils and the council
so
we will be putting that together and
putting it through the scoring index
and that will be
ready for the the next uh council meet
at the next ovn scrutiny meeting which
is
uh it's in may isn't it charles yeah
yeah in may um
and obviously if members are can then
choose a new topic because obviously by
that point hopefully we'll have cabinet
will have considered the the coastal
waste one so we'll be in a position to
start the next scrutiny review and
members can obviously choose depending
upon what the score is to to bump that
one up and do that one next or if
there's another topic in there that
members wish to pursue then we can look
at that one as well so
thank you and that's one of the things
that in particular we mentioned at
ramsgate a week or so ago
how we can input into that if it becomes
a topic
for review
and scrutiny
there is of course an outstanding report
sorry
just to plea that obviously margate
doesn't have a town or parish council so
can we not be left out and the charter
trustees be included
[Laughter]
thank you
there is of course an outstanding uh
report
when i say outstanding i mean it hasn't
been presented yet
not so bold as to call it outstanding
but the one on the blue plaques
monuments street names and so on
we really have been from a personal
point of view something i was looking at
with with the group um we've been
waiting for a further statement since
january the 27th 2021 which was the last
time the government spoke on the matter
to indicate that any changes would need
to go through due planning processes
where they were appropriate and so on um
i am happy to report that just the other
day
the minister michael gove issued another
short statement so rather than me sit in
front of you again next time and say
nothing to report
i'm hoping to be able to put something
together and and then perhaps um not
only as a scrutiny committee but as a
council we can uh make a formal comment
and recommendation to cabinet and then
on to council in the normal way so it
hasn't been forgotten about the
memorials and plaques and street names
but it's just the government have been
rather quiet in the last
couple of years perhaps they've had some
other things to deal with but um
we are we are going to bring that back
or
i will bring that back as soon as
possible
okay um then that's the next one then is
the forward plan and exempt cabinet
report
list excuse me oh dear
is there anything in particular
the members would like us to consider
from this
are we going to let the natural business
of the council have its way and it will
come back to us eventually when the time
comes i'm sure okay
members then we're asked to note the
report thank you very much to our
officers for supporting us this evening
and that concludes the business at 8 45
for this meeting of the overview and
scrutiny panel thank you for all the
contributions
so